to present the art-direction awards here
is a Broadway star who went from
barefoot in the park to the
carpetbaggers and still is approved by
Good Housekeeping Miss Elizabeth Ashley
and escorting her as a member the
Academy Board the father of his own
little league team mr. McDonald Carrie
we have a number of awards to hand out
Elizabeth so will you start gladly for
best achievement in art direction of a
black-and-white picture the nominations
are the Americanization of Emily george
w davis hands peters and elliot Scott
set decoration henry grace and Robert
are better hush hush sweet Charlotte
William Glasgow set decoration rattled
the time the night of the iguana
Stephen grind seven days in May Kerry
Odell set decoration Edward G for server
the Greek basileus Fotopoulos the winner
is
Vesalius fotopolous during the Greek
it's a great honor from me and from my
country is very nice it's very nice very
sweet I thank you the hours of the
Academy of the work from this honor
believe me is happening
I never imagined from there it comes
the nomination is for best achievement
in art direction of a color picture our
Beckett John Bryan and Maurice cutter
set decoration Patrick McLoughlin and
Robert [ __ ] right Mary Poppins Carol
Clark and William C chunky set
decoration a male Curie and Hal gauze
men my fair lady Jean Allen and Cecil
Beaton set decoration George James
Hopkins the Unsinkable Molly Brown
George W David and Preston Ames set
decoration
Henry Grace and Hugh Hank what a way to
go Jack Martin Smith and Ted power set
decoration Wolverine Scott and Stuart a
reach the winner is the winners are Jean
Allen and sessile VP for my for ladies
so many people to thank but we won't
want to say to miss audrey hepburn and
she liked our sets up so we really can
win these awards thank you